Hello ! Euh ouais, je voulais raconter
une histoire.
Euh hier, j'ai euh je travaillais
euh donc écoutez rapidement là,
je remplace je fais du remplacement dans
les bars et cetera pour donner un coup
de main parce que quand j'étais quand
j'étais jeune, j'ai fait beaucoup de
restauration des bar puis une fois on
demande de remplacer puis j'avais fait
dans le passé j' fait une erreur
justement dans un système En tout cas,
puis il y avait eu un problème qui
sétait arrivé
puis tu sais rien, c'était pas une
erreur qui était dramatique. C'était pas
un non jugement ce que j'avais fait.
C'était vraiment de quoi qui était
bien basic, tu sais que peu importe
n'importe qui qui travaillerait aurait
fait un peu la même erreur que moi
mettant
puis que c'était juste pas encadré puis
c'était pas structuré pour pas que ça
arrive. Donc puis on m'est venu vers moi
euh en mode vraiment hyper euh
comment qu'on pourrait dire hyper
agressif euh full en mode tac tac tac tu
as fait ça tu as fait c vraiment en mode
exagéré au niveau des émotions sur
qu'est-ce que tu as fait puis
l'ampleur que ça prend au niveau
émotionnel à mettant
fait je doute pas que c'est sûrement
déjà arrivé que vous avez eu un conflit
avec quelqu'un ou que vous avez eu vous
avez fait telle erreur puis quelqu'un
était vraiment pas content contre vous
autres puis a commencé à vous crier
après ou peu importe ou que même que
vous autres aussi vous avez embarqué
pour embarquer dans dans la dans la
chicane mettant qu'on pourrait dire puis
ça l' monté
puis hier ça m'est arrivé puis justement
le premier réflexe que j'ai
Oui, tu fais tu fais un saut, tu fais tu
t' attaqué. Puis
moi, j'essaie de plus en plus, j'essaie
de plus en plus avec la méditation et
cetera de vraiment prendre un peu de
recul puis d'accepter euh ce qui
m'arrive puis vraiment analyser pour pas
toi-même embarquer dans tes émotions
puis embarquer dans tes pensées. Ben
voyons le remet de sa faute, l'ego sans
attaquer puis et cetera.
Puis j'ai eu de la compassion pour cette
personnel. La personne était était
tellement pas contente, elle était
tellement
euh
envahi par cette
par ses pensées, par ses problèmes que
une petite chose comme ça parce qu'au
final c'était c'était banal. On pour
dire c'était banal. les erreurs que j'ai
fait c'était banal puis la cause la la
problématique que ça amené c'était oui
quelque chose de désagréable mais c'est
au final il y a dû payer quelque chose
pour réparer je pas toutexliquer mais
mais c'était comme si ça prenait toute
l'ampleur de la situation puis il était
vraiment envahi par ça
mais
là je me j'ai comme sempathie pour pour
cette personne-là parce que tu dis He
pour te laisser envahir tes pensées, tes
émotions pour de quoi d'a banal que ça
il y a pas personne qui est mort tu sais
loin de là loin loin loin de là
puis te laisser env par ça c'est que tu
es vraiment pas bien à l'intérieur de
toi c'est tu vis des tu vis des choses
tu es pas en paix tu vis énormément de
stress euh tu es pas bien avec toi-même
tu sais c'est ça le
Le réflexe que tu peux remarquer dans
les dans les réactions des gens quand
les gens ils vivent des du stress, quand
ils vivent la tristesse, quand il vivent
de la colère,
ben au final c'est uniquement eux, c'est
leur jugement de la situation, tu sais.
Puis si ils étaient en paix, ben des
choses comme ça, çaarriverait pas. Ils
seraient pas emporté par la situation
parce que la situation, elle est telle
qu'elle est. C'est le jugement que tu en
fait qui fait que la situation est
mauvaise ou bonne.
Donc ça pour dire que j'ai eu l'empathie
cette personne là
puis que je souhaitais que ça j'ai comme
j'étais comme je souhaite que tu te
libères de tes souffrances. Je sais pas
c'est quoi tu vis en ce moment. Je sais
pas c'est pourquoi tu es autant stressé
que ça. Pourquoi tu vis autant de colère
que ça, mais genre je souhaite que tu
sois en paix. Je me rend mal pour cette
personne là.
Puis ça m'amène à un point qui est
pourquoi l'équanimité c'est autant
important que ça en tant qu'entrepreneur
?
L'équanimité, on a parlé vidéo, mais
c'est le fait de pas juger les
situations en tant que positive ou
négatif. Ne pas avoir de désir pour des
situations qui sont agréables, pas avoir
d'aversion pour des situations qui sont
désagréables. Juste de laisser des
situations telles qu'elle est puis les
accepter tel qu'elle est sans jugement.
Puis en tant qu'entrepreneur, c'est
énormément important parce que tu vas
vivre énormément de haut, de bas, euh de
problèmes et cetera puis que ça peut
être facile de se laisser emporter dans
ce dans ce tourbillon là de il y a tout
le temps de quoi qui arrive, tu e
attends, il y a de quoi qui arrive de
bien là, tu as attiré, tu as attiré, il
y a un autre de bien, tuas attiré, tu as
tiré là des problématiques, oh ça va pas
bien puis tout le temps dans ta tête
puis au final tu vas jamais être heureux
si tu passes ta vie dans cette dans ce
réflexe là mental de juger les
situations t qu' ben juger les
situations
en fonction de positif négatif puis de
désir aversion parce que comme ça c'est
la meilleure solution pour être
malheureux toute ta vie puis toujours
insatisfait
euh donc là vous allez me dire pour
comment qu'on peut être équanime comment
pratiquer cette équanité là parce que
oui c'est une tâche qui est continuelle
c'est un travail que tu vas faire toute
ta vie d'être le plus économe possible
de travailler là-dessus pour apprendre
comment tu réagis apprendre
comment moins réagir
pour justement être le plus en paix
possible et plus heureux. Donc, je me
suis fait des petites notes sur mon
téléphone pour euh des petits conseils
rapides qui sont pratiques. On va y
aller rapidement euh à la suite comme
ça. Donc, ben d'abord la méditation,
c'est le premier point, c'est le plus
euh le plus évident, mais si tu
m'hésites pas, tu es entrepreneur,
tu vas te mettre la vie tf man. Tu vas
te mettre vraiment la vie tof, tu vas
pas apprécier, tu vas
être plus difficile.
Tu vas passer toute ta vie avec des
problèmes, avec tu vas tout le temps
rouler dans ta tête tout le temps puis
tu vas passer à côté de ta vie. Puis la
vie c'est pas dans 10 ans, c'est live,
c'est le moment présent.
Fait si tu m'édites pas sincèrement
comment faut que tu commences à
t'intéresser à ça, c'est c'est ça va
changer ta vie.
C'est pas pour les mo bouddhistes. Les
plus grands entrepreneurs du monde
méditent puis ils disent comment ça
change leur vie. Euh
donc méditation quotidienne essaie de
faire 10 minutes le matin, 10 minutes le
soir. Sincèrement juste ça ça peut
vraiment être game changer. Pourquoi le
matin ? Parce que pendant la nuit tu
rêves, tu penses plein d'affire toutes
tes problématiques puis ta tête quand tu
te réveilles roule déjà. Puis juste de
prendre un moment avant de commencer ta
journée pour OK, on se calme, on s'encre
dans le moment présent, ça va être
énormément pour être heureux pour tout
le reste de ta journée. Puis le soir,
pourquoi ? Parce que pendant toute ta
journée, tu as accumulé plein d'affaires
dans ta tête, plein de problémati plein
de problématiques, plein de stimulation
sur ton téléphone, plein de whatever.
Puis là, ta tête à roule.
Donc ça prend un moment pour calmer ton
cerveau, calmer ton esprit, te recentrer
le moment présent pour après ça mieux
dormir pour passer mieux une meilleure
journée le lendemain.
Deux, essaie de faire du journaling.
Journaling aussi très bon point de te
poser des questions sur qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans ta journée, comment tu
as réagi ? Qu'est-ce qui était bien ?
Qu'est-ce qui était moins bien dans ta
réaction ? Puis pour justement si tu
mets pas sur papier, il y a pas de trace
de qu'est-ce qui s'est passé, tu as pas
de OK, j'ai quelque chose à améliorer
qui est sur papier. Si tu le nommes pas,
si tu mets pas sur papier,
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
l'améliorer. Ça reste abstrait. Tandis
que quand tu le mets sur papier, tu
passes de l'abstrait au concret.
Donc ouais journaling donc des
questions, ça peut être quelle émotion
j'ai le plus ressenti aujourd'hui ?
Qu'est-ce qui a déclencher ces émotions
là ? Et puis est-ce que ma ma réaction
était proportionnelle à l'événement ?
L'autre par la suite, essaie de faire
des pauses de 30 secondes régulièrement.
Peut-être met un cadrin sur ton sel à
chaque heure juste à un moment que tu le
tu la ça sonne. Tu fais OK, tu déposes
tout, tu fermes les yeux puis juste tu
te concentres sur ta méditation pendant
pendant ta tu te concentres sur ta
respiration pendant peut-être un 30
secondes, une minute juste pour puis tu
fais ça quotidiennement à ta journée,
ben quotidiennement régulièrement à ta
journée, ben tu vas voir que tu vas être
beaucoup moins stressé, beaucoup plus z
beaucoup plus en acceptation avec
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ta journée.
Un autre point que ça c'est chat m'a
donné une exposition volontaire à
l'inconfort. Donc d'essayer de te mettre
dans l'inconfort volontairement puis
d'essayer de contrôler tes émotions, ton
jugement face à situation à ces
situations là
puis de t'observer juste voir OK e je me
suis mis dans telle situation
inconfortable comment je me suis senti
pour mieux pour mieux contrôler par la
suite pour que par la suite quand tu des
situations que tu ne contrôles pas ben
tu es déjà tu as déjà des skills tu as
déjà pratiqué pour que quand les
situations peut-être inconfortable qui
arrivve, ben tu sois plus confortable
dedans.
Euh
ouais. Puis le dernier point, non le
moindre, euh je trouve que un des livres
qui est euh qui est game changer à ce
niveau-là, c'est euh Power of Now euh le
pouvoir durant présent en français euh
de Écartolé
Game Changer. Moi sincèrement, c'est mon
livre
que je pense qu' a le plus changé ma vie
puis qui a sincèrement je pense qu'il
peut si tout le monde euh lisait ce
livre làà
en enfant puis appliquait les les ce qui
ce qui est là-dedans dans ce livreelà
puis vraiment imprégnait son cerveau,
son mindset, sa vision du monde en
fonction de ce qu'il y a dans ce livre
là.
La vie tout le monde serait beaucoup
plus heureux. beaucoup plus en paix.
Euh, il y aurait pas de guerre, il y
aurait pas de
ça serait euh la vie serait complètement
différent.
Donc euh
donc euh
tout est ton bord. Salut là. Yeah.